hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game from round two of the Greinke
chess classic 2019 if you've seen
yesterday's game played between world
champion Magnus Carlsen and young Vince
here you know that young wins didn't
really have all that much time to
prepare for the next game as they played
a seven hour game and it was really just
uh it was really just torture and when
you face Carlsen for for the first time
in your life and you play a game you
play an excellent game against him and
you somehow manage to lose because you
well struggling in time trouble to
choose between two options one is one is
the only one that doesn't lose and the
other one is the one that loses but you
just don't have enough time to see why
it loses and then you have to face
former world chess champion which one a
time and the next day with the black
pieces it's just you know it's just
great so without further ado let's just
check up on some of the photos we have
and some footage from this round both
compliments of the Greinke choice
classic video team so if you remember
yesterday we've shown this photo where
our young Vince is giving Magnus the
stare there we have it the deadly Vince
stare you might think okay he had enough
yesterday after facing Carlsen but not
really here is a photo from today here
you can see young Vince giving Anand the
stair and we also do have two very nice
footages there we have it here we have a
nice footage of Anand although it's not
moving so there seems to be something
wrong with my OBS so let me just try to
refresh that nope still not moving let's
try it one more time
no still just a photo of on and even
though it's some it's a it's it's a
video but yeah it I guess it just
happens but we do have a nice
short footage of bins here somewhere
late just to get in the movie so there
would have it now let's check out the
game so what do you play with the black
pieces against Anand Anand opens the
game with E 4 and you have C 5 so Vince
goes for the Sicilian defense night to
have three with D 6 and D for violent C
captures Knight captures with Knight to
f6 Knight to c3 and here everyone was
very eager to see what young wins will
go for and here he did go for a six we
have denied Earth and it's a well it's
something you could characterize his
brave as you could characterize it as a
lot of things but as Anand is at one of
the worlds well greatest experts on the
knight or defense alongside mercy mercy
all the Grove it is it's definitely
something you want to play against on
because you want to play him there where
he is best so Aaron goes Bishop to d3 I
with E 5 attacking the knight on d4 and
now Knight goes back to e 2 with Bishop
to e7 and both players Castle and here
the game can see continues in a similar
fashion as the one played between
Nakamura and the maxime beaugeois Grove
from the outer box Norway challenge in
2017 so nice the g3 taking control of DF
5 square Bishop to e6 preparing
controlling d5 square preparing to pull
d5 and here Knight to d5 not allowing
black the [ __ ] 5 we have Bishop
captures pawn captures and now just g6
by young Vince of course capturing the
pawn is not possible if you captured in
just Bishop captures on e7 gets rid of
the pawn and then picks up at the knight
back so and not something you want to do
here Evans goes for g6 it's the same
idea as
maxime beaugeois graphic in stock camera
in the LT box no voice challenge in 2017
and here we have c4 now controlling the
d5 pawn and this is not a favorable line
for black as there is only one game in
the database and it is the one that we
mentioned Nakamura versus Maxime of
Sherlock rough and here in this position
Maxime went Knight the EA T prepared f5
but Vince does not continue in this
fashion here Vince goes Knight B to d7
it's a new move and well now Anand is a
pretty much out of book so he he has to
start playing real chess so rush up to
h6 and I was developing move attacking
the rook Vince moves at rook to e8 and
now rook the c1 developing yet another
piece bush of the f8 hoping to trade off
the darks were bishops but Aaron is in
no hurry as his dark squared bishop is a
is an excellent piece and the Vincent's
not so much at the moment so he just
moves it back Bishop to g5 pinning the
knight on f6 with h6 by Vince Bishop
goes back to d2 and now comes a five he
runnin goes b3 just strengthens his pawn
center here a pawn chain on the Queen
set also prevents a4 and with h5 by
Vince and here you can see that although
black is doing fine here here there
there is this principle of not playing
on both sides of the board but it's a
really old principle I don't know which
game is it I believe it's Karpov versus
Kasparov where Karpov played in both
sides of the board and Kasparov said
something like this is not how you play
chess and then cuz power really took
great advantage of it but then you see
alpha zero playing chess alpha plays on
both sides of the board and everything
is fine so is it really a principle it's
hard to say I guess like like everything
in chess it's up for debate but okay
Aaron goes rook to e1 develops the last
rook and Bishop now back to g7 as it's
much more useful piece there h3 by Anand
and now Queen to e7 which perhaps ideas
of pushing e4 Bishop to e3 and now comes
Queen to f8 you could push this but
after Bishop to c2 you're never getting
your Knight to d5 squares 95 just bishop
here pins this night and now all of your
pieces are going after this e4 pawn
you're just gonna lose it and it's not
there there's not all that much you can
do here so after Bishop to e3 we have
Queen to f8 and now comes Queen to d2
with h4 by Vince kicking in the knight
back Knights the e2 and now comes
Knights to h5 and here on
three maneuvers the night night the c3
and finally f5 by Vince here Vince is
threatening f4 if he is able to you know
do this he will trap on us a dark square
Bishop here and now Annan can go about
this in a few different ways he can go
Bishop to g5 which which happened in the
game but there is also the sneaking
Knight b5 idea which allows f4 and then
after Bishop day 7 it's actually a very
nice piece on a7 even though it's really
all looking it controls this night so
you're not really going anywhere
anywhere with it if you go Knight c5
Bishop can just capture it and create a
past D pawn but Anand decides not to go
for this he goes for the more casual but
up to g5 just a nice nice
better move getting rid of this f4
threat and also threatening the h4 pawn
which is quite a weak point there's
really no good way to defend it Vincent
does find a way to defend that he goes a
Knight to f4 and it it is a very nice
idea because now they found and captures
then rush up to h6 this was the
Vincent's idea are now lining up the
bishop with the Queen and the rook
behind the Queen and now you don't
really have a lot of options here Bishop
knife captures on h3 is a thread this
was number 2 check which would win the
Queen efore is a very strong idea so
here you would just basically have to
move the Queen and allow this win of the
exchange after Bishop captures on c1 so
after Knight to f4 with Bishop captures
on f4 instead of H 4 of course Island
doesn't go for this he captures on f4
and now another nice idea where the f4
point cannot be captured if you capture
than just rook captures captures and
Bishop captures on c3 wins the knight on
c3 and of course the game so after it
captures on f4 we have looked to e6 the
story a rook to e6 by Ireland a very
nice rook lift now if black captures on
and creates a very strong past East six
pawn and also the d6 pawn becomes very
weak so Knights the e5 by Vince
Bishop to e2 Anand doesn't allow the
trade Bishop for a knight and the only
now rook captures on e6 we have D
captures on e6 and now rook to e8 events
finally brings his last rook into the
game and now
Queen to d5 for the moment defending
these six pawn but also threatening the
b7 pawn and here we have Queen to e7
here Vincent defends the b7 pawn but
also prepares to capture on e7 on e6 we
have night to be five by Anand now
forcing a series of crates because well
d6 is just weak here we have Queen
captures but now Queen captures on b7
rook to e7 attacking the Queen and here
Anand just goes Queen be a check King
has to go to h7 and now Queen captures
on d6 Queen captures Knight captures and
now Bishop to f8 and here you can see
that Anand is up upon six points at the
Vincennes five and Vincent also has a
double def born so Anand is much more
enjoyable and it is very easy to play
this position
Anand just has to play a 3 B 4 and he
already has to connect two passports on
the Queen side so a very tough endgame
for Vince
Knight back to be 5 by Island now comes
Knight to c6 and now King to f1 just
defending that Bishop Desmond sent was
threatening to capture it looked
'if i and now comes a 3 just preparing
that b4 move the knight is protecting
the a 3 point so there's no danger of
losing it
Bishop to c5 diamonds and now Bishop to
f3 the most precise idea threatening to
capture the night here you're asking
where is the knight gonna go you can go
back but it's hard to say if this is one
of those cases where knight move with
the knight back is the strongest move
here Vincent goes a knight to d4 he
allows the trade Knight captures with
Bishop captures and here rook to be one
here b4 is now prepared we have looked
east six by Vince now preparing to meet
b4 with rook to b6
but Allen doesn't mind everything is
calculated precisely before we have rook
to be six and now comes look back to d1
attacking the bishop here Vincent moves
it with Bishop to b2
attacks the e3 pawn and here just c5 and
it was actually in this position on move
43 that young Vince resigned the game so
it took and twice as twice less moves to
2
win a game against twins then it took
Carson but Carson did have the black
pieces and start to say was a was Vince
tired after yesterday's game against
Magnus or was he just maybe feeling
overconfident because he he lasted so
long against Carson that he went down
this fast against Anand but it's it's
just a an amazing game by Anand that
that he was able to take it down Vince
so fast and I mean what if he resigned
of course you have to do something about
it your rook is under attack once you
move it let's say Ruby eight you get
rook d7 check and now you're the path
for this pawn is pretty much clear King
will move and now the B captures on a
five you can even mess up your pawn
structure the trip captures are now just
c6 Bishop to b4 attacking the a5 poor
now just a6 Bishop to a5 taking taking
the c7 square but not just a 7 and after
rook to e8 here you will just have to be
careful not to mess up with something
like c7 and allow rook to e1 checkmate
this would be very unfortunate but if
you play something like g3 Justin
creating a square for your King then
everything is perfectly fine then just
let's say captures you can go c7 and now
after rook you want check you will move
G captures on f2 King captures enough to
route back to e 8 and now finally you
will bring a queen into the game black
will have to give up the rook and then
black will have to give up the bishop nu
will have an easily winning endgame but
of course both anand and vincent saw
this and after this very nice c5 move by
Anand vincent simply resigned to the
game yeah a tough tough two games first
round and second round against the the
world champion and former world champion
Vishwanath on Allen for young Vincent I
was uh it was a very eventful round and
it's still not over as I'm recording
this couple of games are still being
played so we will not discuss discuss
the standing cell as I will be showing
at least one more game from round 2 of
the of the Greinke just classic 2019 and
let me just check for the last time is
this video going to move or is it still
just gonna be a still image of Anand
I have no idea why why this is happening
it's very strange since this is the
video this is not a photo but okay I
mean it's it's still a nice photo but
yeah that's the game a very easy victory
for a former world champion Vishwanathan
Anand against young Vince so we'll see
how Vince pharisee in round three so
it's a tough tournament for him his 300
rating points a low-rated then pretty
much everyone in this tournament and you
know normally for everyone everyone in
this term and doesn't want to score
below 50% but for him
III would think 50% is the dream here
although it will not be easy but but you
know it's a very interesting event so
I'm very very interested to see what
what will happen next and also if any of
you are fans of Game of Thrones you know
do share your thoughts in the comments
below what are you expecting that will
happen in episode 2 as I'm also waiting
to check that out today sure I would
like to thank Tucker's show blood
Sandra Booker's Umar's Dixit Chris
Picard and Bradley Beatty for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
think all for watching and I will see
you soon with some more hopefully
interesting content we're continuing the
ranking chest classic coverage and I
would definitely recommend the checking
of the two links in the description
below first one is an interview with
Magnus Carlsen from his yesterday's game
after his yesterday's game against Mintz
it's really an amazing interview by the
cranky chess classic video team and the
second one is impressions from day one a
lot of amazing video footage do check
that out as well both links will be in
the description below the the first two
things you will see so do check it out I
think you'll have an excellent rest of
your Sunday and I will see you soon and
happy easter everyone